au maroc c'est demain que le premier
avion transportant des étudiants évacués
d'ukraine devrait atterrir à casablanca
de nombreuses familles avaient tenu un
sit-in à rabat devant le ministère des
affaires étrangères pour demander de
l'aide aux autorités notre correspondant
jean marie lemaire a pu rencontrer un
couple dont le fils était unité était
étudiant en ukraine ils ont pu le
joindre par téléphone écouter
débloquer
mon coeur de maman et meurtri je
n'arrive pas à me concentrer sur les
choses banales du quotidien je ne dors
plus et quand j'y arrive je fais des
cauchemars
chaque fois temps de faire transfert
manqué de génie noir
je suis installé à ni pro
je pensais pouvoir y rester
j'espérais que les tensions aller vite
s'apaiser
mais non
l'armée russe y est entrée dans la ville
et nous avons entendu plusieurs tirs end
alerte
alors j'ai décidé de partir avec mes
amis
damon thomas que vous êtes à la gare là
oui oui le train vient d'arriver il faut
que j'y aille à niakhar thoiras d'accord
mis d'accord c'est bien
je veux un t il y à du thé ici rudy
parce qu'il fait froid ici
donc il va franchir la frontière de
moules bavière et la frontière de la
roumanie on compte il arrive à la roma
les je vais voir réserver le billet de
oubliez d'avion pour nous rejoindre à
kazan
est ce que je
j'espère
à ce moment là vous pourrez souffler
enfin enfin compte il arrive on va on va
faire la fête je le crois